okay why don't we go ahead and get
started since I usually introduce the
speaker I'll introduce the speaker which
I think as you know today is me and I
like to give a talk in this conference
each year and it turns out that just
like some of you who are presenting at a
mia and other places need to do practice
talks this is for me a little bit of a
practice talk for a talk I'm giving in a
few weeks right after the a Mia meeting
and it has to do with my research so I
think as many of you know my research
focus historically has been on
information retrieval or search
something I was doing before things like
Google and PubMed existed and obviously
those major commercial successes have
have changed the information retrieval
field though like a lot of fields we
still it doesn't mean we should stop
doing research and trying to figure out
what works so and you you all know me
bill Hersh I'm the director of the
program also actually if someone can I
don't know if anyone's going to tweet in
any questions but if people are out
there listening and someone does want to
tweet in if maybe someone can monitor
the hashtag D mice comp I'll be happy to
answer any questions that come in that
way so I'm actually giving two Talk's
today in fact let me pull my phone out
because I'm gonna want to time the
second one just get it ready so
basically the the purpose of this in a
couple weeks actually this is a year of
twenty-fifth anniversary in addition to
the big anniversary there's a initiative
I've been involved with for that's been
around for 25 years called track the
text retrieval conference it's a annual
challenge evaluations and in many of the
fields in which we were
there are these challenge of al ua
shion's that bring together a research
community with a common data set so
people can compare many of them try to
be academic so not not like commercial
bake-off although sometimes they take on
that flavor and Trek is one of the the
granddaddy's of challenge evaluations
and this year is the 25th anniversary my
major role in track has actually been in
introducing biomechanical tasks into it
which has has has been something that a
lot of the predominantly computer
scientist audience of track has wanted
to participate in and one of the things
that we've been able to do is is
actually the relevance judgement so I'll
describe what those are in a moment but
basically the gold standard on what's
relevant and should be retrieved and
we've always had a ready source of
people with expertise and so I've done
work in that in the trek tasks to also
help with relevance judgments so so so
basically with the the talk at Trek is
about 25 minutes so I thought what I
would do is I actually have a little
primer on information retrieval some of
you know about it some of you have taken
my courses but it's just an overview of
the concepts all of the people attending
Trek will all know all of that material
so so I'll do this primer initially for
you guys especially those who don't who
haven't been as familiar with
information retrieval and then that will
put you in the pepping enough knowledge
to understand the actual talk that I'm
going to give which I will time because
I need to do it in under 25 minutes okay
because this is clinical informatics
Grand Rounds in addition to our usual
conference I have to provide learning
objectives so what our objectives are
are to define the evaluation measures
that are used in information retrieval
some of you are familiar with them in
different contexts and then I'm going to
talk about some of the the biomechanical
tracks that have been part of the trek
challenge evaluation and then describe
some of the findings what we've actually
learned from them so information
retrieval what is it many of you have
heard me talk about it before I've
written a book on the topic actually in
a third edition and talking about
possibly doing a fourth edition at some
point but it's the focus on the indexing
and retrieval of predominantly
knowledge-based information although
information retrieval has moved off in
different directions historically back
in the early days of information
retrieval when computers couldn't hold
much more than titles and abstracts of
articles that was the focus but as its
expanded to full text and images and
videos and datasets and patient records
and so forth the field has evolved so
just to define a few terms again
probably most of you know these terms
but for the few who don't basically the
goal in information retrieval is to get
to content which just really is broadly
anything we want to retrieve documents
articles web pages images datasets etc
in order to be able to find that content
we undertake a process called indexing
which can be a human indexer and that's
what the National Library Medicine does
to assign mesh terms and can also be a
computer program that those may be like
what Google does extract all the words
or it tries to be a little bit more
sophisticated and do natural language
processing and things like that but
basically identifying the content and
other attributes
so for example if an article talks about
article might be have been funded by a
grant or is published in a journal some
of those attributes as well and that
basically comes out in the form of
metadata then as users we want to
retrieve that content we do it by by
formulating queries that are phrased in
the metadata so we can match and that
process is called retrieval and there's
typically a search engine that's the
software that does the matching between
the queries and the content so what are
the use cases for information retrieval
historically it was finding documents
finding journal articles other kinds of
documents webpages etc as computers
evolved and we could put images on them
information retrieval expanded to
retrieval of images retrieval of sounds
video etc and of course then as our
networks evolved then we could put that
kind of stuff on the web the the
retrieval expanded its focus again to
those sorts of things on the web and I
mean sometimes for those of us who have
been working in search for a long time
and search is another way that we
describe information retrieval it's been
amazing to see it go from something you
know I can remember dating myself a
little bit here in the 1980s when only
librarians searched or people who had
accounts for things like CompuServe and
AOL and now of course you know everyone
does it you pull out your phone you pull
out your computer whatever and then also
information retrieval has expanded in
other ways clinical data and I'm going
to talk about one of the trek tracks
that looked at using information
retrieval techniques to try to identify
patient cohorts for various purposes and
then another new one that a couple of
you in the room are involved in with me
is looking at retrieval of datasets as
we move into the
data science data analytics world we
might not want to search for a document
we might want to search for a dataset
what's the metadata associated with that
I'll talk about that a little bit so
evaluation of retrieval systems has
always been important maybe more so for
those of us who are on the research side
although even another shift in the
information retrieval world has been
where people who study it go they used
to all go into academia now you go to
information retrieval meetings and
you've got Google and Yahoo and
Microsoft all those folks looking to
snap up those bright young emerging
graduate students but in any case the
part of the research has always focused
on evaluation and and that's always been
of interest to me I think in part
because I've come into information
retrieval different from a lot of my
computer science colleagues from a very
biomedical perspective and so how how do
we design information retrieval systems
that help biomedical users whether it's
someone who's looking for articles about
genes or clinical trials or patient
information whatever so there's
different ways that we evaluate systems
there's I was like to categorize things
I think you can put them into two big
categories of system oriented retrieval
where we're looking at the evaluation of
the system and then user oriented
retrieval where obviously the user is
using a system but the the focus really
is on what the user hopes to get out of
it can they answer questions can they
find what they're looking for
how do differences in the user interface
affect how they use the system and so
forth on the system side and system
evaluations are easier to do especially
if you're a computer scientist working
in a computer science department
somewhere without perhaps ready access
to users like we might have here in a
more of a biomedical setting in the
system oriented approaches the main
everything derives from two core
measures of recall and precision recall
accion I'll define them but they're
they're based on proportions of relevant
documents I'll define them I think in
the next slide and then sometimes we
might want to combine them into an
aggregate measure and we get things like
mean average precision something called
beep ref and I'll explain what those are
because some of the results come at us
in those measures when we're looking at
users the focus might be different we
can actually apply things like recall
and precision when we're looking at how
well users use a system but we might
also want to look at what is the user
trying to do how well can they do it
what problems do they run into and so
forth so when we do system oriented
evaluation we need some kind of data set
which in the jargon of information
retrieval is called a test collection
and test collections really have three
components one is the content that we're
searching on so in the early days in
biomedical information retrieval we may
be focused on MEDLINE abstracts large
collections of them.they the content and
in newer times it might be images some
of you remember Jayashree Kalpa the--
kramer who was a fellow here who did a
lot of work on image retrieval which and
i was involved with that too and I'll
actually talk about it briefly it so we
when we have a test collection we need
some kind of large realistic collection
of content we want to be as realistic as
possible so that we can tell so that we
can look at the experiments and think
that they would generalize to other
realistic kinds of evaluation of
retrieval settings
we then need topics so what are people
searching on in the most simple form of
what we sometimes call ad hoc
information retrieval where you
essentially go up to a retrieval system
put in a query get results back
we so we need some set of topics in
these test collections and then we need
relevance judgments of the art of the
content items whether they're articles
or images or whatever that will retrieve
which ones should be retrieved which
ones are relevant to those topics and so
we build these test collections I've
been involved in many of these over the
years big and small some of them are
small enough to fit on old-style tiny
hard disks other ones are huge in size
and basically when we when we do the
evaluation we do we do what we call runs
we it's all done in a kind of a batch
sort of mode where you take the topics
and you give them one by one to the
search engine and you get your output
and then because we know about relevance
we can measure things like recall and
precision okay so let me define recall
and precision I know that some of you
know what it is but basically recall
let's just assume and it's not always
easy to realistically assume this that
we know every for every topic we know
every relevant document or image or
whatever out there that we want to get
so recall is when we do a search of all
the relevant ones that we could get what
do we actually get so if there is a
hundred relevant and we get 50 than our
recall is 0.5 or 50% those of you who
work in the medical diagnostic test
world will know this measure as
sensitivity the so recall is of what we
can what's out there what we can get and
and fine but when we if we do our search
broadly we might get all the ones we're
looking for but we might also get a lot
of ones that we don't want that are not
relevant so the other measure is
precision so of what we get back what
proportion of that is relevant and
there's it's not a direct mathematical
trade-off but in general
if you do a really broad search you'll
bring in a lot of stuff that you don't
want if you do a narrow search you'll
miss things that you want and you've
probably experienced this when you've
actually done searching precision again
for the medical test people is
equivalent to positive predictive value
so when we do this relevance based or
system based retrieval all of the
measures emanate from these two things
sometimes we want to combine them into a
single one and I won't some of these
have fairly complicated mathematics but
in essence things like mean average
precision and basically combines the two
measures together so you get a single
number so you can actually compare one
system against another with a single
number
beep rap is a measure that that tries to
take into account so some of these test
collections are so big that you can't do
relevance judgments for every you know
you some of these test collections have
millions of records millions of
documents or images or whatever so you
can't do every last relevance judgment
beep ref makes some assumptions and
enables us to come up with a measure
when we haven't judged everything for
relevance and some of these further ones
normal discounting cumulative gain also
allow for other things like graded
relevance judgments instead of a binary
relevant or not again I don't have time
to go into all the details of these but
you can think of them though as as ways
of aggregating recall and precision and
and taking into account incomplete
judgments so let's talk a little bit
about challenge evaluations many fields
use this I know in the bioinformatics
world that or machine learning world
cago competitions use this sort of thing
and database people of others use these
sorts of things although in information
retrieval this has been around for quite
some time
25 years of Trek the idea and
information retrieval is that you
develop a common task the the most
simple task is you want to find relevant
documents on a topic but there's other
perhaps more complicated tasks like one
of the ones we'll talk about is
identifying patient cohorts from medical
records and and again you ideally aim
for a realistic size collection that
that is reflective of the real world
that the tasks are reflective I've
developed a number of these test
collections we've at times actually gone
out to real users and see what kinds of
things they search on and use those for
for the topics when we build these test
collections there's some research from
the information retrieval field that at
a minimum you should have about 25 to 50
of these topics to get stability across
the measures when you do these analyses
you can apply standard usually repeated
measures kinds of statistics to see if
because you'll get differences and then
the question is always are they
statistically significant and then the
way these big challenge evaluations like
Trek work is that there is a lot of
different research groups that
participate and one of the ways to get a
good representative cross-section of
relevance judgments is to have a lot of
different groups do these runs and they
all get pooled so that the the more
different approaches to retrieval you
use the the more diverse kind of content
output you get and so your relevance
judgments are across a more diverse set
of documents or images or whatever and
so that's how these test collections are
built I think yeah just a diagram and
how Trek works what one of the things
about information retrieval is that
machine learning is actually relatively
new to information retrieval so there's
not a lot of training sets training data
these days people come in
and that where's the training data and
because information retrieval the I we
do have training data now from things
like previous years events but
historically there wasn't a lot of
training data but the idea behind track
is that so all of these participating
research groups come together in the
case of tracks some are from academia
some are from industry other places they
all participate in this task where they
get this common data set this test
collection and then they have these
common set of topics that they run
against their systems they produce these
runs and they submit the results and
then in the case of track there is a
group at NIST the National Institute for
Standards and Technology which is the
government agency that has has chosen to
fund this particular work they the all
the documents are pooled and relevance
judgments are performed and then the
results are sent back out to the
participants and in fact then once you
have the test collection you know you
can tweak you know you can go back to
your system you can tweak this parameter
that parameter and see what works better
although the one of the challenges with
that is you know starting to overfit
your system to to that to the data but
historically that's how people have done
a lot of research and information
retrieval with these test collections
want one a few other points about these
test collections one is that because
these data sets are so big you just
can't assume that even when you have
pretty comprehensive relevance judgments
that you have absolute and you should
really look at relative comparisons so
how does your system or some variant of
your system perform relative to another
variant of your system or someone else's
system and in fact one a lot of times we
do for consistency enter judge
reliability we do multiple
ovince judgments and you find that
people's systems tend to do about the
same relatively with different sets of
relevance judgments so which is probably
a good thing so that that way you don't
have to be too worried that you know
someone maybe judge this document wrong
or that document wrong systems that do
good with in general with one set of
relevance judgments tend to do good with
another for the same task and test
collection that's not always the case
across different tasks and test
collections another thing that we find
with information retrieval actually show
it to you from one of the tasks is that
some queries are really easy people do
really well some are really difficult
and people do poor and then we tend to
just average we always want a single
number that describes how our system
does and we average it and sometimes the
averages obscure the interesting results
and I'll show you some examples of that
so there is actually a number of other
challenge evaluations that have taken
place in information retrieval a lot of
them emanate from track Trek is really
kind of the granddaddy of them all it
actually started I shouldn't I actually
have that wrong should be 1991 because
it's 25 years or wait you know 1992 was
the first year so this is the 25th year
of Trek and most of the focus in Trek
has actually been on non biomedical
things news wire web searching question
answering things like that and it was
starting around like 2001 2002 that I
actually started the first so-called
domain-specific track and track which is
was actually the genomics track I know
you tend to think of me on the clinical
side but there was a lot of interest in
that that's you know when the lot of the
gene sequencing was really starting to
heat up and we were focused on
literature though not not so much the
gene sequences track spawned another
thing
called clay which now stands for
conference and labs of the evaluation
for him but initially stood for cross
language evaluation form in places like
Europe where there's many different
languages spoken in proximity to each
other cross language retrieval is
actually a big issue maybe it's less of
an issue in the United States since we
tend to do everything in English but
anyways clay eventually broke off from
Trek and began its own yearly challenge
evaluations but one of the interesting
things with clay was that there was a
group there that got interested in image
retrieval and some of the people within
that group got interested in medical
image retrieval and them knowing my
interest in all things biomedical I got
involved in the image clay medical
retrieval task which was right about the
time that Jayashree was a fellow in our
program and and its really turned out to
be her major area of research and it was
actually it's actually kind of fun to do
image retrieval and then Trek has
inspired other things like some of you
may know about the i2b2 tasks which are
more focused on natural language
processing and then something that a
couple of you are involved in because
I've lured you into it is there's a bio
caddy is an effort funded by NIH to
create metadata around data sets that's
the hot topic now and so there's
actually a challenge evaluation that I
was asked to be on the organizing
committee of and will participate in
where there's a collection I think it's
about three quarters of a million
metadata records of datasets that are on
various mostly NIH sites and of course
that's what we might be interested in
these days is you know find me a dataset
on this disease or this gene or some
combination of them so one other way
that I like to look at information
retrieval is as a funnel so at the top
if
if we're focused on scientific
literature we're focused on all the
literature the first step is that we
want to extract out things that are
possibly relevant for us and that's
really information retrieval when we go
to PubMed we do a search and we we want
to go from all of the world's literature
to a set that we can manageably look at
that might be relevant for us of course
we really want to find things that are
definitely relevant and the way we do
that now is we look at the screen and
make those judgments but fields like
that go variably by names information
extraction text mining try to do some of
those things in an automated fashion and
then ultimately we want actionable
knowledge whether we're doing a research
study or developing a clinical decision
support rule or something like that so
that's another way to look at
information retrieval okay so at this
point so that's my exit let me just stop
here if there's any questions I can
answer them then I'm going to launch
into my Trek talk which I'm actually
good at I'm any questions comments if
not that's okay okay let me let me
proceed on yeah sure and and we always
want people to press the button so those
listening online can hear Thanks you
said we're starting to have training
data sets we can train again it's like
from like does the bio caddy have one in
there what are the top training sets you
recommend yeah well I think it depends
on your task so in the case of bio caddy
which you're interested in - you know
there are people now that want a search
for you know all these ever-growing
numbers of datasets there's other people
that might want to search for biomedical
literature there's other people that
might want to search for newswire you
know all these various collections of
information so I don't know that you
could say that the best set is the one
that actually fits the task that you're
interested in so you know for those of
us who are
focused in the biomedical world you know
we might be more focused on things that
are biomedical and if right now we're
interested in finding all the you know
helping people find datasets to do their
biomedical research better then then
that would be the right choice for us so
is there a call for somebody to kind of
curate and make public training sites
that everything compete against like we
do at handwriting recognition yeah that
there are there that you know I missed
has been really good in sponsoring Trek
and for at least for the information
retrieval field that's been probably the
largest development of sets the I to be
two initiatives for example have that's
been initiated by some grant funding of
the mostly the NLP community so they're
you know they're there's actually some
legal test collections and there have
been people in the you know legal field
who have developed those so they tend to
come about in various kinds of ways but
you know usually it's a combination of
someone who has a real-world retrieval
challenge and and then someone who's
willing to fund it so that's what kind
of happens yeah Dana
now there III think that the IR
community has the IR community actually
used to be pretty insular I think with
the growth of things like Google and
PubMed it's it's you know become more
public but there are some there's some
crossover laughs in the communities but
but not a massive amount okay let me let
me move on and as I said I want to start
my timer here okay so in in a couple
weeks I will be giving this talk to this
25th anniversary celebration of track
there will be people talking about how
it started there's other actually one
other thing that that's actually come
out of track is actually the IBM Watson
system because another track within
track has been question-answering
they're developing systems that not just
give you the document but actually try
to point you to the you know 250 byte
window of text that actually is likely
to have an answer to your question it
was the IBM's group participating in
track that was the forerunner of what
they now call Watson so ok so I'm gonna
speak to this group kind of give them an
overview of these biomedical tracks I'm
first going to tell them a little bit
about why information retrieval is
important to those of us in biomedicine
and I'm gonna go through these different
tracks and then talk a little bit about
other kinds of research in information
retrieval evaluation beyond these
challenge of al ua shion's so why is
information retrieval important in in
health and medicine well one is and this
probably isn't unique to medicine but
it's certainly a challenge in medicine
and every single day that we live
another 75 clinical trials and 11
systematic reviews get published and so
if whether you're a practicing clinician
or
whether you're a research or whatever
that's just a lot of literature to keep
up with you you probably can't keep up
with it all so you need good retrieval
systems to find what you're looking for
when you need this graph some of you
have seen this paper by Bill stead who
notes that as the world of genomics
which many of you work in starts to wind
its way into clinical medicine the
number of data points per clinical
decision that physicians will need to
make about patients will well it already
has exceeded the kind of human cognitive
threshold but it will continue to go up
and if the vision of precision medicine
comes to be there there may be hundreds
of data points that a physician has to
take into account when making a decision
on patients so that's another case for
information retrieval another case for
it is the fact that everyone's doing it
you know patients don't just walk into
doctors offices anymore they're sitting
there on their phone searching Google
with their symptoms and you know I think
I have this or they saw a commercial on
TV last night that says ask your doctor
about this great drug so people need to
know how to do information retrieval
we're actually starting to teach it in
the medical school here for example
there's also some of you know about all
the concerns about reproducibility of
science and so being able to know all
the studies that have been done and to
ask whether some of them need to be
reproduced is important for information
retrieval and and just everything about
precision medicine will exacerbate all
of these other bullet points so back
around one was well the paper we the the
work started around 2003 2004 there were
lots of people from the computer science
world you know asking Weinke you know
can we do searching on you know at the
time that was when the bioinformatics
explosion was beginning and because
computer scientists don't really
necessarily make a distinction between
those who do clinical and bio
they looked at me oh yeah bill you know
how the bio stuff sure you know there's
a track in your program called
bioinformatics so um but you know it was
a hot topic and so in fact we were
actually able to get a National Science
Foundation grant to fund it so anytime
there's a grant opportunity it's a good
thing and so this was the first time
that Trek moved beyond things like
newswire to what what we now call
domain-specific because there's people
who do legal information retrieval
chemical information retrieval etc and
we so we got this grant and we wanted to
look at realistic problems that really
genomics researchers were facing and the
problems then not too different from the
problems now are you know you might
learn you might discover a gene variant
that might be involved in in what seems
to be a completely different disease
process or a pathological process
physiological process whatever and and
so we initially focused on on just this
ad hoc retrieval find me more
information about this but as time went
on we actually took up this
question-answering approach where you
try to be more specific about what you
retrieve not just this whole document
but a sentence or a paragraph that
actually potentially answers your
question and a kind of intermediate to
that is something called passage
retrieval where you're maybe not focused
on the text of the answer but you want
to zero them in on the part of the
document because someone might do a
search and get this huge long document
and then they have to spend a lot of
time going through it so a second
function of an information retrieval
system might be to try to point them to
the area of where the what they're
looking for might be so the information
retrieval research community had found a
number of techniques that
worked well one of which is well some of
them are things like stop word removal
so removing common words because people
typically don't want to search on da and
and and which and things like that
techniques like stemming where you pull
the common suffix is so so coughing and
coughs are reduced to cough different
kinds of waiting we we tend to think of
Google as the gold standard of waiting
and Google does a certain type of
waiting that works really well on the
web but doesn't necessarily work in a
non hyperlinked kind of document
collection and the Google algorithm
depends on links between documents and
if there's no links there then Google's
you know just a nice fast search engine
query term expansions so looking at ways
of adding terms to the queries of
everything from finding synonyms to
those words or words that occur in
relevant documents and folding them into
the query and so some of those things
work pretty well and with with the
genomics documents the and this has
probably been true and a lot of the
domain-specific things some of the
vocabularies that we've developed mesh
gene ontology things like that
have been helpful in when you if you can
identify that the users interested in a
certain term and then just pulling in
all the different expressions for that
term that the user won't necessarily
type into their search with with
question answering the same sort of
approaches query expansion worked also
with question answering you know again
we're trying to point someone to the to
the actual text that doing that passage
retrieval of narrowing it down and and
in you know how do you actually decide
what the passages are the the best
approach for passage retrieval is just
this mindless overlapping
200-word windows you know as opposed to
trying to identify the paragraph breaks
and the section breaks and things like
that and those sorts of things worked
well and the trek genomics track it
generated a lot of interest people would
use the track content after the track
was over people continued to publish
papers in fact if you go to my google
scholar profile you know ranks your
papers by how many citations the most
cited paper I have is a paper from
nineteen ninety four that was the first
test collection I ever created and
people always cite that paper when they
use the test collection so it's a way to
get citations for your work I wouldn't
consider that paper to be my my best
paper that I've ever written but it's
the one that gets cited the most but
part of the problem with an information
retrieval is that people when they write
papers they don't always give really
good descriptions of what they've done
with their systems and so you can't
always figure out what it is that
they're doing and then a lot of times
you know people will do well they'll do
a study you know we improve so-and-so
over the baseline and people will choose
something that sometimes deliberately
has a low performing baseline and then
yeah we improved 50 percent or a hundred
percent over it so those kinds of things
can happen so a second task was the the
image retrieval that wasn't actually not
part of Trek but it was an image image
retrieval Sam running a little bit late
it kind of came out of the clay which
had been derived from track but
Jayashree
and others we were able to get some nice
collections of medical images and one of
the things you might ask about images
you know what's the best way to retrieve
from them do we retrieve from the text
do we retrieve from the try to process
the image a lot of image
analysis people but we found that that
the text is the most consistent way to
retrieve images maybe someday our image
retrieval image processing capabilities
will be good but for right now the best
way to find an image is to find is to
search on text that describes that image
there were a few other variants I won't
go into another one it's probably one of
my favorite tasks in track you know
track kind of responds to what's going
on in the world so after the high tech
act you know which you've heard many of
us talk about you know electronic health
records and all that NIST thought well
you know can we do something in track
with medical records and this led to the
medical records track the some of you
may know Wendy Chapman from University
of Pittsburgh she's now at university of
utah but they had developed this
de-identified collection of about it's
about a hundred thousand electronic
health record documents from about
17,000 patients and now with the issue
with medical records is the task isn't
the same we don't necessarily just want
to go you know find me you know like you
know the word chest pain that occurs in
an electronic health record it may occur
as no chest pain so the the task is
different in that we're probably a
better use case for searching on the
text of medical records is to identify
patient cohorts and dr. Wu back there
has actually taken this work further and
I actually collaborate with him and he
gave a talk about it last year but that
work kind of had its origins in the trek
medical records task so we were able to
get this collection of de-identified
medical records and our use case was
identify patients who might be a
candidate for a clinical study XE cohort
identification in medical records is
actually a big challenge I don't see
anyone from oaktree here but they get a
lot of requests for data when people are
trying to identify cohorts that they
might want to recruit
into a clinical study so you know again
part of the context of this was you know
now that we have these growing amount of
electronic health records and people
implementing them and but the problem
with electronic health records is that
they're not while there's some issues
around protection of say journal
abstracts the the it's not a sensitive
information because these records were
actually real people they've been pretty
scrubbed of the real people their names
and addresses and things like that but
privacy is a big thing in fact this was
the ultimate undoing as I explained in a
moment of this task so we had this test
collection we did the same sort of thing
where we developed topics basically
looking for patients cohorts of patients
with this condition or and/or this age
group or things like that and it was
actually very successful experiment we
did it typically in track they'll do
tracks more than once because people
they get better over time but try to
create a new test collection each year
so this is what the test collection
looked like basically there were about a
hundred thousand reports some of them
were not actually mapped to actual
patients but so it's about 93,000 and
mapped to different visits when people
come to the healthcare system they don't
just get one record they might get an
admission note progress note a radiology
report a surgical report and then
ultimately a discharge summary so there
tends to be a number of documents per
visit now because of the D
identification some of these this is
probably not 17,000 unique people but
because of the D identification and this
is a problem with the identifying data
we had to break the links between
different visits but still it was a very
useful test collection
and so different groups participated the
NLM group from the Lister Hill Center is
always there we participated too and one
of the things I wanted to show so these
are the the measure was this inferred
normally normalized distributed
cumulative game don't worry about what
it means it just know that one is is you
know basically a hundred percent success
and zero is none the one of the
interesting points is how much variation
there is on the different topics so
there are some topics where everyone
does really good and there are some
topics where most people do really
poorly there's also some where a lot of
people do poorly but then one query or
another seems to do really well and this
is the the research side of this trying
to figure out what makes these systems
perform well in general with this task a
lot of the common things that work in
general search systems didn't really
work here but again one of the
successful things was this query
expansion using terminology systems and
so forth and other people tried to
recognize negation that didn't really
help much mapping queries into the Pico
some of you know the the patient
intervention comparison outcome thing
that didn't help much but people have
done interesting work and it even turns
out that just using the the old
antiquated icd-9 vocabulary helped a
group in Australia achieve some of the
best results so that and then one other
thing we did Tracy Ettinger many of you
know when she was a fellow this paper
she actually looked did a failure
analysis this is another aspect of the
research that we do which is to
try to determine why things that were
retrieved but not relevant or relevant
but not retrieved and we tried to look
at the reasons and some of these are
kind of things that you if you think
about when you do searching you
recognize can happen in any type of
searching so although in the case of
medicine topic terms mentioned is a
future possibility so the patient
doesn't have a disease but in the chart
in the patient's record the physician
wrote you know patient at risk for this
in the future
sometimes there's timing issues patients
handed in the past sometimes there's
disagreements on what patients have
[Music]
sometimes the the search system for
whatever reason doesn't pick something
up or or if it has a scoring algorithm
it ranks it low and so other ones
sometimes there's synonyms or lexical
variants that that the search system
misses so these are the kinds of things
that we need to think about when we're
developing and trying to improve search
systems and it gets a little tricky with
medical records because they're not just
like an article in a journal they may be
referring to things that happen that
might happen that different clinicians
might disagree with each other and
finding and things like that so that was
interesting work the the that track
unfortunately ended because the
University of Pittsburgh started getting
cold feet about so many people using
their theoretically de-identified
clinical data
it's unfortunate now I'll mention a
little bit more about that at the end so
we went back to using journal literature
and some of you maybe not many of you
might know Kirk Roberts from who was at
NLM he's now at UT Houston we developed
this thing called the clinical decision
support track where
the the the we didn't want to totally
give up patient information so we took
patient cases and then the different
research groups could do what they
wanted with them to trying to find
information on these different topics
and we group them into categories of
diagnosis testing and treatment and
that's the current track that that we're
doing right now in the future you know
Trek is not immune to the fads shall I
say probably shouldn't say that being
recorded in in medicine you know so
precision medicine which has a lot of
potential so we're kind of morphing this
track into a precision medicine task
where we're also going to incorporate
some of you are familiar with clinical
trials.gov
which reports on clinical trials and to
try to do the precision medicine tasks
of a patient who comes in maybe has a
certain type of cancer
the tumor is sequenced we identify some
variants on it and we want to see if
there's other diseases or at least other
types of cancer that may have that same
variant and that's part of the precision
medicine paradigm so we're moving in
that direction so I've already mentioned
that I mention again here because I it
was in the first part of my talk but
that Trek has inspired a lot of other
challenge of al ua shion's the i2b2
which is a little bit more NLP focused
clay has now further developed into this
a health track one of the things that
they're doing is looking at patient
information retrieval so patients who
have questions about clinical topics
searching on content that's aimed
towards patients how successful are they
in finding what they're looking for and
then we've already talked a little bit
about this bio caddy retrieval this part
I'm actually probably going to drop out
of this talk
cuz I knew it was gonna take a little
bit too long I just wanted to mention
that this the system oriented retrieval
is important for us to figure out how to
build better systems but systems are
ultimately used by users and so you
evaluating users is important as well
and in fact some of the research quite a
bit of the research that I did like
through the 1990s and early 2000s was
user oriented research we used to
recruit medical students graduate
students and sit them down in front of
retrieval systems including this one
this is the system I actually programmed
when I was a fellow called sapphire
where we when the umls met at the source
was first being developed trying to help
users map their queries into common
terms unfortunately it didn't really
seem to help that much more than just
doing text searching but we did it
that's what kind of initially piqued my
interest in evaluation asking about
things like well recall and precision
are important but how much of a
difference is important if you have a
10% difference in recall is is that
going to help someone do their tasks
better you know it probably depends on
the specific task and that's what lead I
won't go into any detail here because
we're short on time but we did a bunch
of experiments with user experiments
having people come in giving them
questions to answer things to look up
and then looking at what aspects of the
retrieval system were important in fact
one of the things we found in one of the
biggest studies we did that recall and
precision actually didn't matter it's a
kind of embarrassing thing to get up in
front of a audience of information
retrieval researchers but but if you
think about it if you know your goal is
to answer a question you don't need
massive amount of recall you just need
to find that one or maybe a few
documents that make you really confident
on what the answer is and we also did
another
where we found that some people that
they they would they would answer the
question ahead of time and then go to
the retrieval system and and they didn't
do any better with the retrieval system
they some of the questions they they got
right but some of the questions the
retrieval system led them in the wrong
directions so something else all these
things you actually need to keep in mind
with with real users so I'll skip to the
end here and so what do we conclude from
all this well I mean first of all
information retrieval it's important in
probably every area of knowledge but
it's it's certainly important for all
the reasons that we know in biomedicine
especially if we borrow the big data
terms of volume of information
increasing variety increasing velocity
the amount of it coming at us increasing
we know that there's varying benefits of
different techniques for different use
cases but in general it seems that these
terminology resources have really been
probably the most effective thing and
they're it's important to think about
the tasks we know that ad hoc retrieval
that kind of going up to a retrieval
system is I would argue that we that we
pretty much solve that problem I you
know with things like Google and PubMed
there's probably a little bit better
that we can get but some of the other
tasks some of the other use cases like
novel types of data so EHR data
structured data and also high recall
tasks which for example the
evidence-based Practice Center folks
when they do their systematic reviews
they they by design do these really
broad searches aiming for a hundred
percent recall but one of the reasons
why their grants are so big is because
they spend a lot of time going through
and eliminating out most of the things
that are not relevant to their
systematic review and some of you may be
familiar with
Aaron Cohen's work that's looking at
ways of making that process more
efficient and then the research the last
thing I'll say which will resonate with
the people that I talked to is that the
research is confounded by some of these
larger issues not the least of which is
is privacy because the real interesting
search problems now are on private data
like for example searching email you
know that's something that like the FBI
is interested in now for various people
the you you I mean I know I personally
would not want to donate my email
archive to someone's research experience
experiment because there's probably
stuff in there I just don't want people
to read obviously patient records and so
you know how do we handle this one of
the things we're looking at and Steven
and with I helping some sent out a grant
proposal to look at like evaluation as a
service where you keep the data in a
private setting and then you send your
system to work on the data and you
actually don't see the data you just get
your results and then also proprietary
data most of the world's search data is
now not really owned but the the
processing of that data is owned by
companies like Google and Facebook and
Microsoft and those companies actually
have active research groups but their
their data is not widely available when
you talk about issues of reproducibility
and and so forth is a problem so I will
stop at that point